- Welcome back, y'all,
to the end of my surprise
40th birthday show.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I'm sad it's ending,
but it was a really great time.
I love it so much,
it's gonna take me at
least an hour to finish off
the rest of that queso fountain alone,
in my dressing room, please.
Okay, maybe 45 minutes.
(audience laughs)
Which reminds me,
it's time for "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
All right, so we've got Tampa-based,
MOR TV on-air personality
Jason Guy on the line,
who's gonna guide me along.
So Jason, great to meet you.
- Hi!
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] So where are you?
- It's great to meet you, Kelly.
Sending you happy birthday wishes from
the eighth-annual Pier
60 Sugar Sand Festival.
You might be jealous here,
I'm in sunny Clearwater Beach, Florida.
- Yes, I am.
- This is a huge festival,
it brings in 200,000 people over 17 days.
People enjoy walking on that pier.
Just think about that stroll.
You can ride a Ferris wheel here,
or even relax on the beach.
But the real star is sugar sand,
Clearwater's most famous natural asset.
And, Kelly, you gotta see this!
It looks and feels just like real sugar.
Ah, it's amazing here.
And sand sculptors come
from all around the world
to create amazing works
of art out of sand.
So this year we're taking
the sand and animals
and creating a theme of Sandimals.
- You like that?
- What?
- So I'm here in this tent,
its 21,000 square feet of sculptures.
There are 150 of them in here.
Everything from an aardvark
to a zebra in here.
And I've got some cool dolphins behind me.
Look at this giant dolphin-
- Amazing!
- And some other marine animals.
And it all pays tribute to the
Clearwater Marine Aquarium.
- I love it, oh, I love an aquarium!
I'm a huge fan.
(audience applauds)
So tell me about that aquarium.
- Okay, so the Clearwater Marine Aquarium
is a great place
that not only takes in these
sick and injured animals,
but they work to rehabilitate them
and hopefully release them,
so it's really great the
aquarium gets this tribute.
It's a great way to honor
all of the good and amazing
work that they're doing here.
Now, there is one thing that's
happening at this festival,
there is a Sandimal sculpture
that hasn't been revealed
to the public, yet.
It is a "Kelly Clarkson Show" exclusive.
- Oh my god! (laughs)
- Are you ready for this?
For your birthday,
Happy Birthday!
- Oh my god!
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
We've got Henry as a Sandimal.
- Oh, you have Henry!
- [Jason] And of course,
Henry's best friend.
- You included my dog!
That's so nice.
Oh my gosh, I love that.
- I know, this guy and all of Florida say
Happy Birthday Kelly.
- Well thank you so much.
Oh my gosh, it was so nice.
(audience cheers)
Thank you to Jason Guy,
Tampa-based MOR TV,
and the Pier 60 Sugar Sand
Festival in Clearwater Beach,
I wish I was there right now.
I'm liking that post right now.
(love react button dings)
And that's not all,
our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly,
which is exactly what the
Pier 60 Sugar Sand Festival
is all about,
so they're writing a check to the
Sunsets at Pier 60 Society for $1000.
(audience applauds)
So love you, thank you for that, Pilot.